with hungry mouths to feed
it almost looks ordinary
but everyone here knows another wave of
Russian missile strikes could come at
any moment targeting energy supplies and
turning off the power yet no one runs
away
this couple has stayed in the capital
since the first day of the full-scale
war yeah
foreign
Russian attacks this week after waves of
strikes caused widespread blackouts
the chances are it won't last but no
one's panicking
this was the response to an air raid
warning at a forum where the mayor was
due to speak
give is under the raid alert but we are
on the ground we are in the shelter and
we will continue our work
the tally kitschko urged residents to be
prepared for anything even long periods
without power the Russians to bring try
to bring depression of citizens instead
them I talked to our citizens they is
very angry and ready to stay and ready
to fight it's a sentiment held by even
the most frail
a determination to defy the dangers and
dig in
Deborah Haynes Sky News Kiev